in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
atopic eczema the neverending itch
that's what we talked about today with
our studio guest dr. Philip RIBA from
Berlin hello and welcome to in good
shape
isn't it amazing we can fly you to the
moon we can transplant the heart and
even build artificial hearts but we
can't stop the skin from itching why is
that that's true we all know where the
moon is so that seems fairly easy where
to go but we don't really know whether
it comes comes from we have several
causes of itch
for example internal diseases such as
diabetes or kidney diseases but also
infectious diseases as chicken pox we
all know how much there is each when we
have chicken pox and of course there's a
lot of dermatological diseases like
atopic eczema that caused a lot of itch
there's many aspects to it and we
haven't really completely understood all
the aspects so we don't know it can only
treat certain parts and that's why it
makes it so hard to treat but do you
know whether the atopic eczema comes
from is it genetic there's a big genetic
component we know that from studies we
know if there is one parent suffering
from atopic eczema about 20 to 40% of
the children will be also or the risk is
that the 20 to 40% will be also affected
with atopic eczema and if both parents
do suffer from nor dermatitis and it's
also about 80% that the children will
also be affected with Nora dermatitis so
there's really is strong genetic
component and then why is it that there
are more children and getting
neurodermatitis than adults again
this has to do something with the immune
system because the immune system isn't
used to triggers and that is why the
body needs to get used to it so usually
atopic eczema kind of flares up in youth
but usually fades away in adulthood so
they can outgrow it exactly that's what
happens is actually good news we got a
view question from New Zealand so Bo -
Bo Queen's daughter from New Zealand
told us that her son
atopic eczema and now he has a fever too
which is an allergic direction it's an
allergy so is there some connection
between atopic eczema and allergies
indeed there is we know that many
patients develop hay fever after they
have suffered from Neuer dermatitis they
can also come together and some patients
also develop asthma afterwards or
together which the whole thing is called
the atopic march because they develop
one disease after the other March like
marching around exactly because they go
together we just saw the patient in the
report and she told us that her symptoms
get worse when she's stressed why is
that there's a strong correlation
between the psyche and the
neurodermatitis this comes also from
history we know neurodermatitis
is part of this is Latin coming from the
nerves so there's one link and we know
that in the MPO genesis also when we
kind of develop in the mother womb
there's MPO genic layers and the layer
where the brain and the skin develop
from are the same so there's a strong
link to there's a lifelong connection
between it okay dialysis for skin
condition this is very new to me
what do you think about this new method
it seems to be a very fairly reasonable
approach and I think it could help but
it's probably not the therapy for most
patients because this is only for severe
patients or severe atopic eczema
services so what actually is the
standard treatment well one of the
basics is maintaining a good skin
hydration that means that the patient
has to use augments or creams on a daily
basis even twice a day
and he has to find out what he likes and
use it really frequently and then should
the patient go and see the doctor to get
some prescription for this ointments or
is it okay just to go into a supermarket
and get something he likes well as I
said the basis is just
any ointment which is good but if
there's a flare-up you should probably
see a doctor and there's the need of
using a treatment like cortisone for
example but on the other hand you have
to cream the skin and every day even if
there's no flare-up exactly this is a
continuous therapy because the skin of a
patient with no dermatitis has a
tendency to dry out so it has to be
moisturized so what about the coat asam
you just talked about this but there are
many side effects of cortisone if you
use it on an on a good regimen by a
doctor there shouldn't be any side
effects a side effects can come up if
you use it too frequently or a strong
good therapy in a part that is very
sensitive so then we can see that the
skin gets thinner or that there's
bruising or the location of the vessels
but there are medications outside there
and which don't contain cortisone the
new treatments exactly there's a
catenary marine inhibitors they have
similar effects same strength as the
steroids okay but they don't seem to
have the side effects of it so they're
generally used widely but you have to be
cautious of side effects when you give
it systemically not ferner dermatitis
but other diseases there has been seen a
higher risk of lymphoma or skin cancer
well and you don't want to get that
there and we got a viewer question from
a Malik Licata from Greenland and from
Nara Rosen Schmidt from Namibia and both
want to know what about sun exposure and
if you go to a tanning saloon is it okay
and doesn't make the symptoms worse so
does it even improve the healing
generally spoken UV light or light is
immunosuppressant so that is a good part
in treating also neurodermatitis but you
have to be cautious because you don't
really know what kind of UV dose comes
out of a tanning bed or out of the Sun
so it is a good reason to use medical
sunlight
UV narrowband treatment and that seems
to work well with a lot of patients and
the medical send let you get we're at
the doctor's office at the doctor's
office
young time from hongkong says that
relaxation exercises have really helped
her cut down flare-ups what do you think
about that well there is a we talked
about that earlier the combination of
psyche and neurodermatitis and I think
and my experience patients really do
profit from methods like this like you
always good to get some relaxation and
they each can stop then thank you dr.
Berger for being with us in the studio
today thank you so much
you
you